лихоманів можна що але не українці ще
живе лося вчора у чеському суді
оветт бум ася незаконні 3 че абсурдне
специфіка ван та політичні судилище
над п'ятим президентом України в ес квіти
так бача в цику праворуч політичні
переслідування алла вчора це було юридич
але давида але через критерії європейських
суден також випито і юрій ти що
зафіксовано кількість і не фальсифікації
ті з праві
збоку офісу генпрокурора то dbr ліберж
абсурдно щоки з вами де хто війна
мотається the west ще пита свейн та весь
ковен ви клонів це указу верховного
воланда командувати вони потрібно
retour особисто харчування кому вигідно
поставити і піцу мені до конституції
презумпції в Україні та нашу оборону
здати nist ви ключ на Україні агресору
ще вчорашні суди вищипали кінного
довелося про за ленського то його 300
wetsuit кови своєї генпрокурор тип
люботина constitute україни
он його гай вчись він і ви вирішили with
men цієї презумпції невинності і при
значить і війни в україні кожного span від
40 мільйонів українців точно
як сталінські прокурори у 30-ти маму
роті причому загорніть вау проти
порошенка порушено з правого відра
джону армію то наказ про counter нас тут
за мінську завгодно і на цих 3 маються
санкції проти рейн та агресора за т.ч.
йшли homo плями не українських церкв було
створи на православній церкві України
3 мани томас у кожен стик сфабрикований
exprof напряму затікав на руси я
алібі тільки не кулька житло встало в
покер і вибрав на витратив на
штуці базі 100 мільйонів гривень вони не
знаєш ну жадібні корупції нічого з цієї
води скільки брехні було вилито на
порошенка за астані рокки чому дорівнює я
чистка двір для кремля то його п'ятий
колони в Україні фактично судять не
порошенка а руками за ленського кремль
судити всю україну за 5 уроків опору у
його мау наш топ 5 президента
з поділася ще шоу здати невриту
ватарі цим зеленого
кали весь цивілізований sreet ризик
відмови суди у vim круглий задню
али роблять досі babe gets
переживання Петра Порошенка в середині
україни щось за кордоном
вона дипломатичному фронті порошенка
вперед продовжуючи ефективно захищати
україну з ту ж дату я і кремль і за
ленського а в середовищі не держави 5
президента допомагаючи людям у коридор їх
ситуаціях за крима
130000 костюм для медики біт порошенка
до помел їзди замовлення офісі по загартування
лікорис 20 до 900 ким а сплачено техніка
у ж винну села прикарпаття пікірую
трохи не
червона і добре але війни геть і бояться
українців суд же в третє переносить сп
одягає ще десятки тисяч людей не
вийдуть на вулицю знов alavann та
з'являються нашу пов'язавши 8 липня
продовжить боротьбу мавпи криво суддя не
побуду вала росію на нашій землі